[Music]
I talk to myself a lot and most of the
time not most of the time some of the
time it's in my head some of the time
it's out loud I don't really realize I'm
doing it until I'm already talking out
loud and it's it can be embarrassing
when I'm around other people and not
really realizing it until it's already
happening and I don't know if that's
[Music]
normal what is what's going on this is
John with the Dr John deloney
show we are recording this um the day
after we got back to the office after
being um gone for the holiday break so
we're into the new year if you're
listening to this it's what February
already or at the end of January yeah
January 22nd good so I hope you're still
staying on all these new things you are
going to do the new year new you
whatever's going on or if you're like me
I really struggled this year like I
wasn't ready for the new year year
wasn't super jazzed about it and now
that it's gotten going we're at the very
beginning of the new now I'm starting to
get into the groove and starting to
imagine all right here's some things
that are going to be different here's
some things that are going to be the
same I'm going to double down on here's
some things I'm going to quit doing so
I'm pretty excited about it and Kelly
yes Jenna had her baby yes so um I think
everybody knows that Jenna was pregnant
and uh she was due in late mid to late
February this show would have been way
funnier if you had just said like we
didn't know she was pregnant and she had
a baby but all right everybody knew so
the things you're going to stop doing
are not those things apparently right
correct okay just
checking wanted to check on that so no
she had her baby and um she ended up the
day after Christmas having to go in the
hospital she had preeclampsia but she is
fine baby's fine he's tiny little almost
four pounds a little peanut his name is
Owen but he is healthy I got screwed
again didn't name it John like we had
planned no she did not um you know well
we'll call it like all the drugs and
stuff that's probably how that happened
that that she named it something
different I agree surely once all the
hormones and stuff she'll figure that
out oh my gosh what have we done change
the certificate change exactly change
everything yeah probably what it'll
happen um probably but no she's she's
home she came home yesterday I saw her
last night and the baby's in the NICU
but he'll be there for a couple weeks
but he is very healthy yeah um just
needs a little little growing he's just
a little tiny peanut some more some more
warmth yeah a little warmth uh he's in
there he's suntanning right now yes just
baking just yep doing a little baking
little growing but he's he's actually
really healthy and um yeah I've heard
this is The Nightmare part for folks
whose baby is in nikku for a while you
can't hold your own baby and it's just
Absolute Total Hell she's she's met him
uh well like she didn't meet him until
the next day like officially see him
she's held his hands but she hasn't held
him yet um but she did tell me when she
had to leave the hospital yesterday she
was crying but she said the nicku nurses
I mean those are just man yeah they're
special special and they told her
anytime 2: in the morning 5: in the
afternoon 8 at night whatever you need
to see him you come up yeah you know
there's no visiting hours there's none
of that that um with Nick you parents
anytime you need to come in here you
come in here and they're only like three
miles from the hospital yeah so that's
great so but he'll just be there a
couple weeks um so she's doing good she
misses everybody and you know was not
she said last night she said I'm still
trying to figure out what happened she
said I went to my appointment on the day
after Christmas and you know for a baby
that wouldn't do for two months and
then I have one and so she's she go back
to your house but the baby's still there
so her head's a little you know um has
spun a little bit but but they're doing
good what a wild world we live in yes
well very cool that we have live in this
little weird sliver of History where
that's possible but in the meantime
we're welcoming Taylor to the tlor to
our little Swift by the way Taylor Swift
she's taking a break from her tour and
she's going to be on the greatest pod
show of all podcast of all time pod show
the oldest guy ever I don't feel old
anymore I'm so old all right let's go
out to Ontario Canada and talk to Jess's
girl what's up
Jesse hey Dr John how you doing we're
doing all right man how about you I'm
doing okay very good man what's
happening is it
cold you know what it snowed a little
bit last night for the first time we had
a we had a white Christmas actually ah
very good man congratulations it was
quite warm oh thanks yeah it was good
what's up all right well I've been uh
really struggling with some anxieties
that I've never really experienced
before
um not not really sure where to go with
it but I know I don't want to feel like
that anymore um I give you a quick
backstory on it I was married for 20
years I'm I'm a Christian man uh my
ex-wife just kind of abruptly up and
left she had her
own kind of mental health issues she was
dealing with and some past traumas Etc
and uh so yeah there was about a
three-day notice and then poof
everything had changed and and this
anxiety that I felt was I mean I got
through it that was five years ago and
uh you know I kind of held on to hope
that you know things were going to work
out I'd be patient about it and uh you
know again my faith played a large role
in that and you know I was I was pushed
and pulled and pushed and pulled and
kicked to the curb and finally I said
enough's enough I ventured out met a
wonderful girl everything was great
seeing for about 4 months and then I
started to feel her pull away and I I
thought I had dealt with all those
anxieties and the this the minute she
started to pull away I was hyper aware
of every single text message the tone of
her voice body language I felt like I
did the first day my wife left and uh
it's yeah it's been you know it's been a
week of of just that just that that pit
in my stomach and I I I need to I need
to not feel like that okay um anytime
somebody says that after 20 years
somebody abruptly
left I always want to push on that a
little bit okay when she when she when
your ex-wife tells you and and I'm going
back that far for a reason okay so I'm
not just just playing around
um when she told you why she
left did she paint a picture of a long
story or is it really like no I woke up
on Tuesday and decid I'm
good uh well funny answer to that is um
she never really told me
why uh it it it it took about two and a
half years for her to to kind of
pinpoint to herself uh why and and and I
guess that came down to she did say she
wasn't happy for a while um there was a
lot of outside stressors outside of our
marriage not saying that I didn't have
anything to do with you know definitely
could have been more supportive more
involved that kind of thing outside
stressors like
what uh she has a daughter who has uh
been struggling with a drug addiction
and um you know we had custody of
grandkids at the time that was um our
child services up in Canada basically
dumped them off at house and said if you
guys don't take them they're going to
get separated they're going to go
somewhere
else so it was uh yeah so did she take
did she take those
kids with her we did yes no no no when
she left you oh uh no uh by the time the
actual split happened uh things had kind
of worked out there and the children
were returned back to them to uh to the
mother okay here here's what I'm getting
at um I don't want you to look at
anxiety as something that you worked
through okay it serves an important role
in your life it just has to serve the
right role okay so um we all have a
friend or hopefully you have a friend
who
would like if y'all were out having a
drink or something and somebody mouthed
off at your wife this friend would be
hitting that person before you even
realize what had happened right we all
want a friend that defends us and then
there's that idiot friend who defends us
like that when we don't need it or don't
want it and it causes like a big melee
right similarly anxiety works for us it
just doesn't always work in the right
place at the right time if you told me
after 20 years two decades of building a
life with somebody you all took on
foster kids you took on an external I
mean you took on somebody else's
daughter and raised them as your raised
her as your own and dealt with all the
mental health and addiction challenges
all that
stuff and then one day someone just she
just
leaves that would shake the sidewalk
that would shake the the foundation of
your life like to where your feet
wouldn't ever feel
secure and so then you meet somebody
after five years and it sounds like you
and your ex are still talking o
throughout this like even though y'all
have been divorced for five years now
yall still are in communication is that
right well there's a little bit more of
that story um I can let you finish your
your thought there go for it go ahead
and fill me in okay so um so yeah um you
know my my ex was always around she was
always kind of kept me at Arms distance
and she's been clear that you know she
has a hard time seeing a life without me
and uh I kind of have to come to the
point and say like look you know I I
can't be your friend I could be friendly
but I need to this isn't going anywhere
this isn't going to get fixed Etc what
did she accomplish by divorcing
you uh did she want to sleep with other
people did she just want to live in her
own house like what was she going for uh
I don't I don't have an answer to that
she did get involved with uh another guy
you know within a couple weeks after
about three weeks after leaving so there
was somebody else and then it was going
to fix everything and then it didn't and
then all of a sudden realize what she
lost right yeah so uh fast forward to so
when I sent in my submission originally
um you know my biggest concern was just
feeling that anxiety from my new partner
pulling away from me well fast forward
you know a week um that partner uh you
know said that it's not fair how she's
treating me she's distant and cold she
has a lot of stuff going on it is what
it is um that put me into this again
that spiral of
anxiety uh and then just last night my
ex-wife reaches out out of the blue
saying that she's made a terrible
mistake
and so right that's that's a whole
another whole another thing but um so
here's the deal the the anxiety's
right it remembered think of it as a GPS
pin your body put a GPS pin in the
moment that the woman you were married
to after 20 years up and left
you it also put a GPS pin and you didn't
know what do you do for a
living police officer oh my gosh of god
dude lead with that man so a guy who
knows everything and shows up to the
worst sit no one calls you because
they're having a great
day and you go and you have to solve
these problems you have to know what to
do next and you now have to know what to
do next in very tense uncomfortable
situations that are being filmed and
broadcast all over the world 24/7
365 yeah and you missed it in your own
house
right yeah yeah your body puts a GPS pin
in something really scary which is Jesse
no longer trusts
Jesse huh and then you meet somebody
new and your body is like man this feels
good this is like a real human being
she's beautiful she laughs she's funny
and then it is hyperaware
to take care of you to love you your
body's doing its job when she starts to
pull away she takes a little bit longer
to respond to that text you know I don't
know if you've been to through detective
Academy but one things they teach you in
detective Academy is walk into a room
and exhale
first and see if you can feel something
that doesn't look right doesn't feel
right your body's doing that for you 247
365 so I think the anxiety you feel is
right on I would be worried about you if
this had happened and you were like all
right cool on to the next I would be
like man you should probably go talk to
somebody fair enough the challenge for
you is twofold one don't instantly try
to make that anxiety go away which
getting back with your ex-wife tonight
because it she would be warm and she'd
be
comfortable would make that anxiety go
away
today and it you'll wake up tomorrow
dude and it will be back with a
vengeance and you know that I do yeah so
head into the anxiety feel
it let let it be a part of you that
sounds that sounds terrible it is but
hey it's like dude you don't go to the
gym and take all the weight off the
bar you go to the gym and put on as
heavy as you can possibly lift why
because there's strength on the other
side of
that and it sucks it's not
fun so when your body's trying to get
your attention head towards you do this
for for a living man you run to the fire
you run at the
shots and no anxiety there whatsoever no
because you've trained it a thousand
million billion times and you trust your
training and and you trust your uh you
trust your
partners but you don't trust Jesse
anymore wow
Fair yeah so here's what I want you to
do with it okay um one I want you hang
on the line I'm going to send you a free
copy I'll mail it up there to Canada for
you of of my new building and nonex Life
Book okay I'm going to send that to you
it's got a road map to it the second
thing is I want you to begin to write
down and every police officer I know
from my dad to my friends everyone I
know all the guys done Patrol with they
carry those little black notebooks I
want you to get a separate one just for
you and I want you to write down when
you start feeling anxious she hasn't
she's not responding to my text she's
not doing this she's not doing that I'm
doing this I want you to write that crap
down and get out of your
body okay later on at night later on in
the afternoon when you get done working
out it's almost always better to do
something physical before you start
reviewing stuff because your body State
changes but want you to go to the gym go
for your walk go for your exercise get
off shift whatever you need to do and I
want you just to take 30 minutes 10
minutes five minutes look at that list
you've written for the day and say is
this
true is this true okay is she really
avoiding me maybe or maybe she had
diarrhea when you texted man and she
just I made that weird I'm sorry but
like no it's she had diarrhea and she
just didn't have her phone with her
thank God I don't want to you don't want
to date somebody that has their phone
with them while they have diarrhea so
like maybe that's what happened or maybe
Noe this is a pattern this is a pattern
and yeah we need to have a hard
conversation yeah see what I'm saying
yeah I'm with you and here's the last
thing I want you to do I want you to be
really really really honest with
yourself I have been unable to be honest
with myself in this way without talking
to somebody else so yes I'm recommending
that all of my police officer friends um
see a counselor have some sort of person
I also recommend that if you can find
somebody that's not in your Precinct
that's not like yeah go talk
to man that's tough stuff because they
got to keep notes but you can go find
somebody off the off the path and
obviously if you need to get help get
help from wher you need to get help from
right um and it's very Precinct specific
as to what kind of care they provide but
want you go talk to somebody have
somebody that you can process this this
one important fact what did I contribute
in my first
marriage because part of rebuilding
trust with Jesse is owning reality being
honest with
yourself man I actually was married to
my job more than I was married to my
wife I actually got home and after being
the person that everyone in the
neighborhood called I also treated my
wife like she was one of the callers
well you need to do this you need to do
this I often fill in the blank fill in
the blank fill in the blank what world
that I create for my
wife that ultimately she was like I'm
out and dude maybe nothing but very
rarely is it nothing I'm confident you
contributed something to that
environment to that world and be honest
about the signs that you missed and
here's what we're doing we're letting
our body know I'm driving again I'm back
in the driver seat of my own life this
is building a non-anxious life but this
is deal with anxiety don't run from
it take those ruminating thoughts write
them down get them out of your
head and then be really honest and
reflective when you start owning reality
choose reality what role did I play in
this
thing and as you head into new
relationships man knock your lights out
and by the way to answer your your last
question your kind of sidebar question I
don't have a problem with it if you
decide to get married again but go real
real
slow really really slow and don't use
your ex-wife as a
Xanax to not feel so anxious
anymore she didn't deserve that and you
don't
either go
slow grateful for you brother thanks for
your service my man every day you're out
there for us grateful for you we'll be
right
back I'm always on the lookout for
supplements food and top-of-the-line
products that enhance your immune system
improve emotional and mental health
vastly improve your digestion and I'm
always looking for ways I can improve my
sleep and Clarity of thought listen I'm
always trying different supplements
Foods powders and potions and recently
without the company knowing I purchased
some of their products with my own money
and I was blown away by the results I
reached out to them and I'm super
excited that organifi is partnering with
me on this podcast to change my life and
yours simply put organifi is Wellness
Made Easy organifi makes nutrition
delicious for everybody organifi makes
the cleanest products available on the
market and me and my kids personally
take multiple organifi products every
single day my life has changed for the
better from what I think are the best
tasting green powders on the market red
powders that I can mix with water for
caffeine-free energy that doesn't leave
me shaking like a salt shaker gold
powders to help me wind down and sleep
immunity protein magnesium and a special
kids line and more organifi takes all
the drama and guesswork out nutrition
supplements immunity support and
cognitive enhancement and it puts it all
in one place for you and your entire
family youall know I like to experiment
and take lots of different supplements
but if I had to answer the question if I
only had one supplement I could take
what would it be I'd start with organifi
invest in your health in this new year
so you can show up for your spouse your
kids your work and your community we
need you go to organifi.com
backone or use promo code deloney at
check out for a 20% discount for all the
Dr John delone show listeners that's
organifi.com
dealone all right let's go out to Tampa
Florida and talk to Emily what's up
Emily hi Dr John I'm doing well awesome
what's happening what's up yeah so my
question is how do I begin to enjoy my
life outside of work
essentially
usually that has to do with
um a life outside of work that you don't
enjoy I mean yeah I don't know I so some
context um I'm a teacher and I work I
mean probably at least 60 hours a week
doing that and then I do some volunteer
work and then I'm getting my um
education master's degree and so I'm
just I'm just kind of always on the go
and then when I get home I'm married and
you know I do have a happy marriage of
course it has its ups and downs but when
I get home I don't intend to feel this
way but I kind of just feel a sense of
just bless like I feel kind of hopeless
and I don't enjoy
anything and it's not that I am looking
to go back to work but when I'm at work
I don't feel that way
essentially does it have to do with the
fact that when you go to work as a
teacher which is what I've been I've
spent my whole career doing that there's
always going to be outliers right
there's outliers in every job there's
goofballs in every job but on the whole
you go to work with a group of people
who have a shared sense of
purpose we're going to change the lives
of these kids sometimes it's we're going
to provide these kids a safe place to go
sometimes it's we're going to teach
these kids and push them really hard
because we think they're capable of more
than they are but you have a shared
sense of op optimism and we're going to
take X and we're going to walk alongside
people until it becomes
Y and then you go
home and you
don't you don't share that same sense of
I've got a partner in here we're working
on the thing together and we're creating
something amazing and we're Crea like
it's X and we're creating y so you get
home and you just
go am I right or wrong I could be wrong
no you're completely right that's not
something I had ever thought about uh my
husband he doesn't right now he's
actually not working at all but um why I
so he I you know I've been thinking
about it a lot this month at first I was
very frustrated with him because I felt
like he wasn't driven right he didn't he
wasn't interested in working um but he
i' I've realized now I think he's
actually struggling from some kind of
depression um because even applying for
jobs was very difficult for him and I
kind of uh took the lead on that and now
that he's gotten offered interviews he's
gotten a little bit more driven about it
um yeah so I think there's something
mentally going on there um I'm gonna say
this and I mean it with all due respect
in my soul and I'm trying to be kind and
loving I don't
care he's got to get a
job yeah the damning nature
of low-level dymia that H this sucks I
got fired or I got laid off or whatever
did he quit or he get fired what
happened he did get he did quit he was
kind of miserable in his last job so he
did quit so there's just you sit at home
and you wait for
motivation you wait for the perfect
thing and it doesn't exist you have to
go manufacture it and you manufacture it
by go get a
job yeah and you don't quit a job unless
you have another job I don't care how
miserable it
is you you you you even if it's hey I'm
quitting the sixf figure job and I got a
job sacking groceries because I got to
do something to
contribute both for my psychology and my
physiology and for like we got to have
money in this
account um but it becomes this this
spiral that's really hard to get out of
I hate this I hate this I hate this the
alternative I mean the the fantasy on
the other side of that is my life will
be so much better if with not this mhm
and then you get home
and and then it's well it will only be
good if it will only be good if and I'm
not good and it turns into this just
poison and here's what
happens you lose respect for your
husband
Fair yeah just say it out loud yes and
and I know that's hard to say out loud
because I know you love him and I know
he's a great guy I'm not saying he's not
a good guy okay
right but it's hard to be optimistic
it's hard to build something it's hard
to have hope and hope is just this idea
that tomorrow is going to be a little
bit better than today or maybe a lot
better than
today and it's hard to have hope when
you don't have
respect yeah
right yeah and for a while you know um
you know I get home and I feel like my
husband he's on his phone a lot even
whenever he's off of work and that just
really frustrates me and so I think
you're correct and that you know don't
apologize for your frustration Emily
yeah you should be frustrated I'm
frustrated for you yeah if he called my
show and said my wife is really
frustrated with me and I don't think
it's fair I quit my job because I just
hated it and now I sit at home waiting
for the right thing I would have a hard
time being compassionate to
him yeah and I would tell him go find a
job today any kind of job at that's
going to be the step forward to getting
some sense in your body that that
um
uh like you start standing on your own
two feet again after being lost at
sea yeah well something I've learned in
the last you know five years of marriage
is I can't make him so what what is your
advice how do I you know how do I help
him um I think there's a couple you're
exactly right and the fact that you
learned this in the first 5 years means
you are way ahead of most marriages
which is awesome took me like 20 years
to figure that out um all right here's a
couple of things one I want you to spend
some time being very honest with Emily
and right now you have been spent a lot
of time being a mother to your
husband and when you're a mom to your
husband I'm going to say this I know it
sounds gross I've gotten some flak in
the past but I don't care it's true no
Mom wants to have sex with their
son M no Mom wants to have intimate
relations with their their son outside
of sex mhm no um you don't want to come
home and have a third job or a fourth
job after grad school and your service
to your community and your NeverEnding
teaching
job and your fourth job is is caring for
this giant infant
adult and I'll go one step further if he
does have some significant depress
depressive issues those are real MH and
maybe this isn't the moment for him to
get a job this is the moment that he
gets his butt into
care yeah just sitting at home on your
phone is a
nogo and so I want you to be honest for
the first time in a long
time with I want you to write down in a
notebook I've lost respect for my
husband because I saw him face
adversity and I saw him bow
out cuz your body feels that you got to
be honest with yourself
okay and I think you have to stop
apologizing for being frustrated and
stop apologizing for feeling burnt out
you know what burnout is it's when your
body says I quit because you're not
getting the message you're trying to
carry the load of two people at your
home and trying to create a home with a
guy who has no interest in creating a
home yeah right that's are hard stuff
and the Second Step here is after you're
honest with yourself and you write some
of these things down and you're probably
going to shock yourself with what you
write
down cuz it's going to be
hard the next step is not to go bomb him
with these things that's not fair to
anybody okay what is fair is you sitting
at the table and saying the
following here are the boundaries I'm
drawing here's what I'm going to do
moving
forward I am going to go see a counselor
because I have a husband that refuses to
get
work I am going to fill in the blank if
I come home and you have not applied for
a single job today and you've sat here
on your phone I am going to take myself
out to
dinner see what I'm saying this is not
bombing him with you need to do this you
need to do this because that hasn't
worked it's not going to work yeah it's
you being very clear about here's what
I'm going to
do I'm going to take care of myself I'm
going to go to the gym I'm going to
continue to work hard I'm going to begin
to eat a little
healthier I'm not going to wallow around
and be mad at you and then be mad at
myself for being mad at you and that
spir you know that spiral I'm talking
about yeah you're like yeah yeah I live
that all the time all right I threw a
lot at you tell me what you're feeling
on the way
back um yeah I think I I'm feeling um I
don't know I feel like I'm I'm a little
worried that it's nothing's going to
change
okay but nothing's changing yeah
yeah yeah um you know and and as you're
mentioning I think these are great steps
just to take care of me because that's
really all I can do I know that um and
hopefully yeah hopefully he'll get the
message but yeah we've had conversations
before where you know I talk with him
and we kind of go over plans that we had
when we first got married and and then
it by the end of it I feel like we're in
agreement and then you know six months
down the road I back and nothing's
changed well and have you sat down and
said I feel like you have not been
honest with
me I feel unloved in this
home what do you mean I love you and I
always want to have sex with you and
I've had four peers what do you mean and
you can say because we made some
agreements and you've chosen to not
uphold your into of those agreements
which leaves me all
alone yeah and those are scary
conversations because here's why he
might say well screw you then I'm
out but right now he said screw you I'm
in
Fair yeah know that makes
sense I guess the the the hardest thing
for you is you don't have an easy path
forward yeah you have uh I'm going to
say nothing and just continue this thing
on and hope he gets a job and hope it
solves all his problems it will not
Emily within 6 months he's going to tell
you he hates this job and it's killing
him and the boss is an idiot and his
co-workers are morons and he's GNA quit
I'm telling you right
now or you can have a really hard hard
series of conversations not about what
he needs to fix but about what you're
gonna
do what do I do in the case that he cuz
sometimes he'll get really frustrated
and say you know oh all these things
that I do for you I thought you know you
loved me you are you telling me that X Y
and Z doesn't mean anything to you like
he gets he can get kind of defensive
like that what would you recommend I do
that's that's how that's how children
respond right which is like well then
I'm taking my ball and going home here's
what you can say you can say I hear that
you have chosen to try to love me in
ways that you
like that make that you have chosen I'm
telling you what I need to feel loved in
this home in this marriage
MH oh so if I just make dinner if you I
never asked you to make dinner that's a
choice you made I did ask you to get a
job I did ask you if you're not working
and you're just sitting here that when
we get home the house is cleaned up and
you're not just sitting there on your
phone play video
games right because that that's just all
that is is a look over here look over
here look over here look over here it's
just a
distraction and here's guys do it a lot
women do it too but guys do it a lot
with oh I'm working all day it was when
my wife told me I'm not asking you to do
that yeah I'm asking you to be here with
me because I had the opposite problem I
was working 24 hours a day
365 was the opposite issue and when I
would come at her with what your husband
does just the opposite oh I do this and
this and this and she's like dude I
never asked for any of that I asked for
you and then I was like oh crap I don't
know how know how to do
that and then it was me cuz I said I do
I had to go figure out that that set of
skills and I had to go learn it and
figure it out similarly on the other
side oh I do this and this and this
that's not what I
asked I asked that we build something
together and you said I do and you said
I'm in and you're
not so here's what I'm going to
do but if somebody throws a little those
little temper tanty things oh you're
just UNG grateful no no what I'm talking
about it's just
distraction just distraction and you may
have to walk away from the table and say
hey I'm going to come back to this
conversation I'm gonna come back in 30
minutes because right now um you're
acting you're you're you're talking to
me as though I'm seven and I'm not I'm
gonna come back in 30 minutes let's
let's let's
reconvene it's hard I don't envy
you but to your husband if he's
listening you have to get a job you got
to go work and if you can't work I know
those people I've sat with them fine you
got to go get
help you got to go see somebody you got
to go check yourself into an impatient
Clinic you have to do the work just
sitting at home on your phone is not a
solution particularly while your wife is
working 60 hours a week plus grad school
plus serving the community
enough be somebody worthy of being resp
ected in your own
home sure quit a toxic job I've had to
do it you've had to do it fine but don't
quit that job for nothing for a couple
of months with on the couch with a cell
phone
now quit that job and go work at a
coffee shop quit that job and start
driving Uber that night quit that job
and go sling boxes at Walmart on the
overnight shift for $25 an hour
tonight and then apply for jobs when
you're not
sleeping
you can't think your way out of these
things on a couch with a cell phone look
around at our culture we're drowning and
I'm just going to think my way out of
this on a couch with a cell
phone you have to go
do Emily thanks for the call call
anytime I have a feeling this these
conversations get harder before they get
better I want you to be honest with
yourself you only have two hard choices
moving forward hard to let things just
be the same way they are and continually
not respect this Manchild that you're
married to or decide I'm Emily and I'm
worth more than this I'm worth being
loved I'm worth a home and a marriage
that I can fight for that I
love I'm going to have that hard
conversation either way your path
forward is hard I say take the one
that's going to result in a possibility
of healing and change we'll be right
back I'm so excited that eight sleep is
partnering with the Dr John deloney show
to take care of our listeners you and
help you change your marriage and change
your life our friends at eight sleep
have created a fitted sheet with cooling
and heating technology embedded inside
called the eight sleep pod the Pod cover
can easily be added to your existing
mattress like a fitted sheet for
individualized temperature adjustments
down to 55 degrees where normal people
sleep all the way up to 110 degrees
based on your environment and body
temperature throughout the night it
cools down or warms up each side of your
bed and over time it learns what your
body needs and it does it automatically
and in turn it improves Your Sleep
Quality like you have to experience to
believe it the eight sleep pod also has
built-in vibration alarms that wake you
up when it's time and it gradually
changes the temperature of your mattress
cover to gently wake you up it can even
provide you sleep and health reports for
each side of the bed including sleep
stages sleep time heart rate HRV and you
don't have to wear anything eight sleep
is the ultimate sleep experience and
it's proven to give you up to 34% more
deep sleep per night and you can stay
married doing it you owe it to yourself
and your marriage to at least check out
eight sleep and learn more go to
8sleep.com to read more learn more and
see if you want to change your sleep and
show up better in your life that's EIG
ght sleep.
/one or enter promo code deloney at
checkout for up to $400 in savings off
an eight sleep bundle go check it
out all right we're back let's go out to
Kate in Philadelphia we're born and
raised what's up Kate hey Dr John how
are you we're doing good how about you
doing well thank you so much and just a
huge thanks to you guys and your team
I'm really grateful for your show thank
you I'm glad that you are in our gang
man it's awesome to have have you what's
up well I am a little embarrassed
slightly nervous I have a weird question
hopefully it's normal but um I'm a
person who I talk to myself a lot and
most of the time not most of the time
some of the time it's in my head some of
the time it's out
loud and I don't really realize I'm
doing it until I'm already talking out
loud and it's it can be embarrassing
when I'm around other people and not
really realizing it until it's already
happening and so I don't know if that's
normal or what I can do to help that or
you know just it's a thing that happens
in my world and was like ah I need some
help with this yeah I I mean there's
there's a lot of things to pull apart
here I
I I don't I don't like thinking in terms
of is this normal or not there's a bell
curve right there's this idea that given
a 100 people 85 of them will do x on a
regular basis semi-regular basis and
seven over here we'll do this in eight
over here like I get that um I like to
think of these kind of things more in
terms of I'm assuming that the talk you
you're talking is not
nice um yeah probably not okay all right
so if you were just like talking about
your grocery list out loud that I can't
imagine that would cause you a lot of
stress my guess is you are pretty mean
to yourself and occasionally you find
yourself talking out loud like God you
suck you idiot like right you're find
yourself in a public space kind of and
people are like who are you so angry at
is that more like it yeah yeah I think
it's it's a combination of that and then
it's also like moments when I felt
embarrassed about something that I did
or behavior or like conversations that I
should have or things that I should have
said and conversations I had with other
people you know that type of thing yes
uh the rumination we love it totally if
you just think about it enough you can
actually go back in time and change what
happened so yes I fig that might be
keep doing that all right so
um I like to think of it instead of is
this normal or not normal as my body
chooses to deal with uncomfortable
situations like
this and I would like to teach it a
different way of handling it period okay
and one of those is I can't believe I'm
so not normal this is so weird and then
your body like just saying that my
shoulders went up around my ears a
little bit and I got a little tint
saying I'm not normal I got to fix this
versus ah my body handles stress like
this and I don't like it so I want to do
something different one of those is
infinitely more compassionate and
curiosity driven and one is more
judgmental you stupid you start in
a hole on one of them right um have you
ever been diagnosed with um
OCD um no I've never been a formally
diagnosed with anything but it would not
surprise me I guess tell me about tell
me about your ruminating
thoughts yeah um it's a good it's it's
pretty broad I kind of ruminate a lot on
a lot of different topics okay but um I
think you know if it's it's kind of a
cute stressors right so if I have a a
negative interaction with someone at
work I do a lot of management of people
and personalities and so if I have a
negative interaction at work I'll kind
of ruminate on that conversation and
what I could have done better or you
know just sort of um any of any aspect
of that
um and you know any any other sort of I
guess interaction with people or
scenarios where I wish I would have done
something different um why do you wish
you would have done something different
where does that like I'm trying to drill
down to the Judgment part why do you
wish that's fair like when you say I I
it's so embarrassing to who yeah that
people actually comment to you or no
even notice because they're staring in
their own weird world that's fair um I
think it's it's yeah I think it's mostly
my own stuff I think there's certainly
some Personalities in my life um that
you know will no matter what sort of
have a their own personal view of me
which I obviously also cannot control
but um you know I just I know that they
used me they view me through a certain
lens and so I just it makes me
frustrated and you know but um for the
most part it's just my own self judgment
for sure so why don't you like
you that's a great question I think I
really do like me there's you know
um I've done a lot of self-work and you
know really spent the last decade or so
learning how to love myself and so
that's been great but it's still you
know always a work in progress um I
think it's just have you learned to love
yourself or have you learned
to
um um act
right yeah I there's 100% a factor of
that um you know I definitely know that
there's certain ways to be um but I
think it's a combination of both like I
said I think it's still a work in
progress for me and that sort of self
Acceptance in those moments where it's
you know where I am ruminating and
thinking gosh I wish I would have some
done something differently there's also
that quiet quieter voice but that's
saying you know no you're normal you're
this is you're human um everybody messes
up or you know it's there's no such
thing as perfect right so that that is a
small voice in the head as well but all
right I'm gonna give you a couple of
tools that I think can transform your
whole life okay okay for real yeah um
I'm gonna write down a quick note to
myself all right so um that way I don't
forget it I want you to internalize this
with all of your might okay rumination
is a complete and utter waste of your
time yeah okay and so here's the problem
rumination feels like important thinking
helpful thinking yeah okay right it
feels like we are replaying this thing
and next time we're gonna fill in the
blank right problem is we never get to
the next time we get to the what we did
wrong why we suck why we could have done
it better and then we just park in that
just swimming pool of shame we just sit
in it yes sir so there's a difference
between rumination and reflection
reflection is a critically important
part of being a healthy human and
reflection is simply a it's got It's
this it's about looking to the past the
good and the bad likes and dislikes and
then tangibly planning for how things
are going to be different in the
future okay for instance like um I had a
meeting with my boss I man I was awkward
I started stuttering and then when I
started stuttering I started speaking
really fast and I wasn't fully prepared
that was
annoying so next time I have a meeting
with the boss I'm GNA be very uh
prepared that's
reflection um rumination is I can't
believe that he right now he's sitting
at home thinking I can't believe I hir
this freaking I got to find a new
person and and your body goes to war it
goes to fight or flight you know why
right because it thinks it's about to
get fired or it thinks it's about to not
have a home or a car or
food and so you start spinning up I
should have said this I'm gonna tell
them this thing you couldn't tell them
this thing because you're an idiot and
it's just this it's a it's a chorus of
voices yelling at you that sound like
one United voice that's a total complete
waste of your time time rumination is
trying to change something in the past
by going over it and over it and over it
and over it again or it's trying to
change something in the future that
hasn't even happened
yet right it's a waste of time it's like
it's practice beray Brown calls it dress
rehearsing
tragedy right so how do you stop it in
that moment where you say when you're
trying to be more reflective reflective
as opposed to ruminating when you say
for example to use your example you know
I had a bad meeting with my boss and I
want to do this differently next time
I'm going to be better prepared next
time how do you like because when I
think through that process my body then
immediately goes into the next step
which is the shame process you know all
that and so how do you stop your body in
that moment to just I don't think it and
let it go I don't think it does I think
when you sit down and go man that was
not a good meeting I wasn't
prepared and you and I'm going to give
you a the the ultimate trick here in a
second second and it's not a hack but or
a trick but it is it's neuroscience and
it's magic um okay but there's a
difference between saying that did not
go like I wanted it to I feel bad about
how it went I feel sad I feel ashamed of
how I I acted in that meeting that's
fair that's fair I'm gonna let my body
feel that because that's right and then
I'm gonna pull out a piece of paper I
carry a note card with me or I've got my
little my little journal with me I'm
going to make sure next time I'm going
to do X Y and Z I make a plan and it's
very short and then I'm moving on okay
it's the
rumination it's the when you start
creating stories on top of the story
right and well I wasn't prepared well I
can't be prepared if the boss is always
making me also do all these other things
and by the way Jenny never does her work
and so I've got to do hers too so of
course I don't have time now we're in
fight ORF flight now your body's pulsing
with cortisol and adrenaline it is not
thinking clearly it is in survival mode
right and I feel like it's unstopped
like it feels like it's a train that
can't be stopped when it starts you know
and it almost feels like I come out of a
a days right I wake up afterwards yeah
so every um Peter lavine's done some
some really Exquisite work on
this that fight or flight is designed to
run from a tiger or to fight a tiger or
to try to kill somebody who's stealing
your mate right or your child yeah and
so it pumps your body full of these
chemicals and in our modern world we
just go
and then we type an email response right
and so that days you're talking about is
it's biochemical it's
real the only way to I have found to
cycle out of it is to go for I go
rucking I put some weights in a heavy
backpack a go Ruck bag and take off down
the road or I go for a walk I've got
some rules now in my personal life I
don't respond to things while I'm
engaged while I'm mad while I'm
frustrated because it's I'm not thinking
rationally at all
at all right so yes that coming out of
that days you're exactly right your
body's got to metabolize that stress
response oh that's why every major uh
religion has uh uh or culture has dance
as a part of it tribal movements as a
part of it because it your body knows
hey we just had a fight ORF flight
situation and we
survived let's all celebrate this thing
together see what I'm saying you're not
crazy now I'm going to give you um
something that has been transformative
for me and I want you to read this book
it's by Ethan cross k r o SS and the
book is called
chatter okay and last I looked he was at
University of Michigan he um studies
that voice in your head that never shuts
up okay and it's a tool I took from him
that has been Transcendent for
me and here's the idea there is a neural
pathway for I for
me
and there is a different neural pathway
for you y'all so think about this one of
your employees comes to you and says hey
my marriage is falling apart and I did
this thing I don't know what to do
next you very clearly can go well Dan
you should fill in the
blank and your body doesn't get
activated doesn't run off into the
woods but when you think I screwed up my
marriage I did this I'm a piece of
whatever ever and I now your body's got
to defend itself because it's at War
right right so what Dr cross suggests is
begin talking to yourself in the third
person and he gave some examples in the
book about um you you hear interviews
with
athletes and they'll say like LeBron
James will be being interviewed he'll be
like well LeBron on that Court LeBron
James
decides and I you know most of us roll
our eyes at that what he is suggesting
is no no no no that is a different
person that is a that is a person who
takes shots that's a person who misses
shots that's the kind of person who does
this kind of work so what I've started
doing is
saying
um here's a good example somebody hit my
car while I was in it the other day a
woman was coming to her fancy BMW right
parked right next to me I just pulled in
I was meeting my my wife and daughter
for a movie and this woman opens we made
eye contact that she opened her door and
just bammed my car door and then she
kind of like made like a huh and got in
her car and her husband was with her and
a teenage son was with her and dude I'm
telling you I was it was the holidays I
was tired I've been traveling I went
full Defcon I was
enraged and I got out of the car and
looked at the dent and I looked at her
and she rolled on the window and goes
what did I do something and I said yes
you hit my car
we both watched you hit my car and then
she goes uh and I said look and there
was a sizable Dent
Kate and she said I didn't do that I was
distracted I I I was I was distracted as
though and here's the thing I was just
thinking in my head just say sorry it's
a stupid car I don't care just say
sorry and then I happened to glance back
and her son is it her teenage son he was
big he's big boy he's like my size
and he looked ashamed for his
mom and in that
moment I locked the car door and I said
to myself John walk
away because if somebody had come up to
me on the street and said hey this lady
in this car doings your car and she's
hollering it's about to cause a
situation and she's got embarrassed I
would say dude just walk away it's a
dent in your car
right John though wants husband to get
out of the car and me and him are going
to settle us the parking lot right and I
want your insurance and you're replacing
my whole door panel and I had a right to
that I have a legal right to have a new
door panel mhm but when I talk to John
I'd say dude just walk away your
daughter's in there you'reall going to
watch a movie together youall have a
daddy daughter date go see what I'm
saying yeah and so talking to John I
stay present because I treat other
people way nicer than I treat myself
totally right so I want you to practice
Kate writing these things down get them
out of your head
okay number one number two you've
probably heard me talk about this on the
show maybe it's been a while I will
often I don't do it much anymore but I
used to do it all the time when I was
trying to break this bad habit I would
yell in my house no real
loud and what I was doing was I was
stopping the imaginary conversations
that I was having all the time right I
just stop it I'm gonna break it I'm
gonna go nope as soon as I remember it
soon as I realize I'm doing this nope
nope nope my wife would just roll her
eyes she would just be like oh my gosh
husband's talking to himself again and I
would break it and then I would say to
myself this has no
value right
none yeah okay then I would ask myself
do I need to do something different
that's it and here it is your body
simply responding to the stress of your
life by replaying things over and over
again and ultimately that leaks out into
you talking to yourself in some pretty
ugly
ways and you just have to decide I want
to teach my body a different way dealing
with stress right and I'm going to
practice that and then the third thing I
want you to do is start talking to
yourself in the third
person okay Kate had a conversation with
the boss it didn't go well well Kate
what'd you learn I need to be more
prepared all right next time Kate you're
gonna be more
prepared that is such a different
conversation than I suck I screwed it up
again and then when Kate says but I
always mess this up and you're like yeah
Kate you've messed up a bunch but from
now on you're not going to mess up
anymore and here's what K Kate here's
what we're gonna do you see what I'm
saying I do yeah I do and I can't wrap
my head around how much how big of a
difference it makes by creating this
psychological distance between me
and my threat response system it's
pretty profound I may see if we can get
Ethan cross on the show I'd love for him
if he's in Nashville i' love for him to
be on the show Dr cross if you're here
join the show that'd be awesome um but
that particular piece of his work has
been really important for
me because again I treat other people so
much nicer than I treat myself so if I
start talking to myself with some space
it allows me to make errors it allows me
to be forgiving allows me to be curious
John why'd you just get mad at your
eight-year-old daughter she's
eight well because of this and this well
maybe you should just not eat that maybe
you should get some sleep and maybe you
should go tell your daughter you're
sorry that's different then I suck at
being a dad and I'm the worst and I N so
try it try it it's it's it's
Neuroscience it's not just woo woo um
but give it a world grateful for you
Kate call anytime we'll be right
back hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life you
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at John
del. all right we are back and hey
hopefully you recognize at the beginning
of the show wait is this the right show
did I get the wrong podcast no we've got
new
music that was performed and really
written by the great Jason Jason Reigns
a good friend of ours who's in the band
my weekly low and hopefully he's in our
band again this year although he's
pretty good so he may bail on us Jason
stay with us but he's an incredible
producer and writer and performer and um
dude I'm really grateful that he came up
with some tunes I was like dude I want
some old school like Limp Biscuit
jams with some Modern twist and he was
like got you actually I didn't say that
at all I didn't say that one little bit
hey in honor of the great and wonderful
Jenna and her new
baby Kelly who is the second largest
Taylor Swift fan on planet Earth she
actually has Swifty tattooed across the
top of her chest right across her uh
collar bones in Old English super
awkward when she wears her her uh her
tank tops which she wears all the time
but you can just see it like just say
Swifty across the top but in honor of
Jenna the number one
fan song Today is called called Willow
by the great Taylor Swift and it goes
like this I'm like the water when your
ship rolled in that night rough on the
surface but you could cut through like a
knife and if it was an open and shut
case I would never would have known from
the look on your face lost in your
current like a Priceless wine the more
that you say the less I know wherever
you stray I follow I'm begging for you
to take my hand wreck my plans that's my
man that's actually the exact thing that
Kelly wrote to me when she has to be the
producer of this show and it worked out
wrecking plans love you
[Music]
guys